et si nous vivions sans argent si nous
pouvions d'un coup de baguette magique
supprimer la monnaie vivre dans un monde
où on partagerait les ressources que la
terre nous donne est ce que ça vous
plairait ça vous tente
moi j'ai commencé à me poser la question
alors que j'étais aux pays bas j'ai
étudié le marketing à l'université de
l'est vous allez dire du marketing à
l'idée de vivre sans argent il ya un
sacré pas à faire ou pas d'une certaine
manière j'avais entraperçu ce monde que
frédéric beigbeder des pas dans son
livre 99 francs le monde de la pub et du
marketing qui consiste en gros à
déculpabiliser le consommateur pour lui
vendre des produits qui ne sont bons ni
pour lui ni pour son environnement
c'est là que j'ai commencé sérieusement
à douter j'étais quelqu'un de plutôt
normal j'aimais bien les soirées bien
arrosées les parties de foot j'étais au
courant de ce qui se passait dans le
monde mais ça ne fait pas vraiment et
puis j'ai commencé à visionner une série
de documentaires qui m'ont permis
d'ouvrir les yeux de comprendre que mon
quotidien mes achats ce que je faisais
avait un impact direct sur le monde que
ça crée des injustices
là je me suis dit ben il faut que tu
changes j'avais deux amis raphaël et
nicolas est ensemble on a commencé à
procéder à une série de changements
sommes devenu végétarien dont on
commençait à boycotter certains produits
qui n'étaient ni éthique ni écologique
on fait attention à la consommation
d'eau et surtout nous sommes mis à faire
de l'autostop pour se déplacer c'est
comme ça qu'un soir on s'est retrouvé
dans une station essence en pleine nuit
bloqués y avait plus beaucoup de trafic
l'endroit n'était pas particulièrement
bucolique mais on était là et on sentait
même très bien
c'est sur ce coup on a même eu une idée
on s'est dit waouh ce serait super de
partir comme ça à l' aventure de voyager
libre sans argent et donc nous voilà six
mois plus tard donc un allemand un
français un italien sur le bord d'une
route aux pays bas donc ça commence
comme une blague mais c'est une histoire
assez sérieuse l'idée avait d'ailleurs
évolué on avait acheté des sacs à dos
solaire pour entreprendre un voyage
jusqu'au mexique en auto stop et en
bateau stop on voulait en faire un
documentaire aussi deux objectifs
principal donc le voyage à l'empreinte
écologique la plus basse possible et
aussi sans argent
le consommer que ce qui est déjà là les
premières 24 heures ont été intenses on
a fait moins de 50 kilomètres on s'est
retrouvé dans une cage d'escalier a
grelotté jusqu'au lendemain faisait au
moins - 10 dehors on est parti en
janvier c'était pas une bonne idée et
surtout affamés le lendemain on attend
quatre heures personne pour nous prendre
en stop
on commence à douter voulait faire les
malins et on se rendait compte qu'on
était peut-être un forcément capable de
le faire
heureusement une voiture s'arrête le
destin nous a répondu nous continuons
donc nous traversons la belgique la
france nous sautons d'une aire
d'autoroute à une eau tendre appuyant
les restes sur les plateaux repas et
nous avons nous arrivons finalement cinq
jours plus tard à barcelone
là c'est une première étape importante
nous rencontrons tout un groupe de
déjantés qui viennent d'un peu partout
qui vivent sans argent ou presque ils
vivent dans des squats des appartements
ou des maisons abandonnées et nous
initier à l'art de la récup
donc nous apprenons à fouiller mais
aussi à demander à la fin des marchés
dans les restaurants dans les
boulangeries pour se nourrir nous
découvrons l'ampleur du gaspillage et
que se nourrir sans argent n'est
malheureusement pas un problème
nous continuons ensuite jusqu'au sud de
l'espagne et ne trouveront la combine
avec les camionneurs qui ont droit
chacun de prendre un copilote avec eux
nous pouvons donc embarqué à bord du
ferry qui amène vers l'afrique
nous posons le premier pas au maroc là
c'est un vrai choc culturel
nous ressemblons vraiment à des
vagabonds à ce stade là nous sentons
mauvais
on peut pas s'y tromper vous apprenons
très vite a expliqué ce que nous faisons
aux marocains avec deux mois assez
simple que vous connaissez sûrement
walou flouze et là les portes s'ouvrent
les gens nous comprenne et nous
découvrons une générosité sans pareil
certains vont même plus loin moussa par
exemple nous trouve sur le bord d'une
route en pleine nuit il s'arrête sans
peur et insiste même pour nous emmener
chez lui il veut que nous restions trois
jours parce que c'est écrit dans le
coran quand on rencontre un passager il
faut lui donner le gîte et le couvert
pendant trois jours le plus fort c'est
qu'au matin du quatrième jour ils
débarquent dans l'appartement les gars
ça y est je suis papa il nous emmène à
l'hôpital insiste pour que l'on prenions
le bébé de quelques heures dans nos bras
que nous nous parlions chacun en
allemand en italien en français et nous
dit que nous sommes un peu comme les
trois mages qui sommes venus annoncer la
venue de son fils il l'appelle ilaria
l'élu
cette histoire cette générosité se
répètent pendant les six semaines que
nous passons au maroc six semaines
pendant lesquelles nous cherchons une
embarcation pour rejoindre les îles
canaries
nous tombons finalement sur un belge à
agadir avec un petit voilier de 10 m qui
accepte de nous prendre nous exultons
nous sautons joie bien entendu pour nous
c'est le premier obstacle franchi la
joie est de courte durée cependant 20 30
minutes nous sortons du port ça commence
à tanguer sérieusement et on se retrouve
en cale pour vomir jusqu'au lendemain
matin
pas très réjouissant mais c'est pas
grave nous arrivons aux îles canaries
là nous passons environ un mois et demi
où tous les matins nous allons au port
pour rencontrer les marins les
capitaines essayer de se faire accepter
dans la vie du port et trouver un bateau
pour rejoindre les amériques
nous vivons dans un squat nous
perfectionnons notre art de la récup et
nous attendons et finalement nous
tombons sur deux italiens marco et
francesco qui avait mis une petite
annonce à la capitainerie
il cherchait deux filles de préférence
blonde pour faire la traversée
vous l'avez compris ils n'ont pas trouvé
et ils ont accepté de nous prendre à
leur place le deal était simple on
nettoie on cuisine on prend nos car on
donne des cours on leur enseigne le
français l'espagnol et nous voilà partis
pour l' aventure pour nous génial c'est
le vrai obstacle du voyage qui saute à
bord c'est une expérience magnifique
c'est surtout pour nous une opportunité
pour prendre du recul par rapport à ce
voyage car nombreux sont ceux qui le
répète vous même vous avez peut-être
pensé dans votre tête le capitaine ou le
dis chaque matin vous ne voyez pas vous
ne voyagez pas sans argent
voyager avec l'argent des autres il n'a
pas tort d'une certaine manière pour
l'essence et l'électricité même les
invendus que nous récupérons était
produit que de l'argent cependant pour
nous notre voyage va au delà de cet
aspect matériel
l'idée est avant tout de d'apprendre un
peu plus rien contrôler et de vivre de
ce que la vie nous donne de ce que les
gens nous apportent de lâcher prise
c'est aussi la découverte d'un autre
monde une autre réalité les gens avec
qui avec qui nous interrogeons les gens
que nous rencontrons nous créons un lien
plus humain avec eux et c'est ça qui
nous anime et nous commençons à rêver
d'un monde meilleur
la traversée dure trois semaines
jusqu'au brésil
là c'est un nouveau choc on se retrouve
avec des centaines de frères d'infortuné
qui eux aussi vivent sans argent sauf
qu'ils ne l'ont pas choisie pour manger
c'est difficile nous grappillons
quelques restes mais nous ne pouvons pas
vraiment nous remplir l'estomac
pour nicolas c'est difficile il en a
marre de ce trip masochistes il est
d'ailleurs pas vraiment convaincu avec
cette idée d'argent pour lui c'est avant
tout un outil qui peut être utilisé à
bon escient
il ne comprend pas notre quête comme
nous le faisons mais raphaël et moi
sommes très têtu nous avons découvert la
pauvreté nous avons envie de nous avons
envie de l'expérimenté jusqu'au bout
nous décidons donc de continuer nous
nous séparons et raphaël et - reprenons
la route
nous retrouvons bloqué pendant trois
jours dans une station essence au matin
du quatrième jour je me réveille en
panique
toutes mes affaires ont disparu mon sac
à dos la caméra tout ça sur le coup
c'est terrible j'imagine que ça est
sûrement arrivé à certaines personnes
d'entre vous quand vous voyagez ça fait
un peu partie du trip mais moi je ne
sais pas trop quoi faire
le sac à dos ça veut dire l'ordinateur
et plein de choses pour faire le
documentaire c'est la brosse à dents et
toutes ces petites choses du quotidien
qui sont importantes c'est le passeport
et la carte bancaire que je gardais
dissimulés dans le sac
au cas où difficile mais assez vite je
me rends compte que c'est peut-être le
destin qui me donne un petit coup de
pouce cela faisait des mois que je vends
tes l'idée d'un voyage sans argent que
je débattais avec tout le monde sur
l'importance de ce que nous faisions il
valait il fallait peut-être que je le
fasse sans la sécurité incarné par la
carte bancaire désormais j'étais
vraiment ce que je prétendais être un
voyageur sans argent nous avons repris
la route et niévès nous a rejoint la
copine de raphaël avec elle ses belles
jambes et son sourire tout est devenu
plus simple
bizarrement nous n'avons pas attendu
longtemps sur le bord des routes
plus facile de trouver un logement et
nous avions l'estomac plein tous les
jours cela nous a permis de voir autre
chose de ce contre en concentrer sur
d'autres aspects du voyage
particulièrement sur les injustices qui
jalonnaient notre route par exemple des
champs d'ananas sur pollué de pesticides
pour répondre à la demande européenne
des hangars immenses faut ou des
milliers de poulets sont entassés pour
faire d eux
ces maquis la housse et sweat shops ces
entreprises des taxes et pour produire
des jeans à bas coût pour les grandes
marques et les cancers des travailleurs
qui sont ignorés temps de rencontres qui
nous confirme dans nos choix
cette idée de vivre sans argent de
remettre en cause ce système financier
n'est pas vaine
nous décidons devenir vegan pour plus de
cohérence pour consommer le moins
possible de choses et repartant de plus
belle et nous arrivons finalement au
bout de onze mois par onze mois après le
départ au mexique
25000 km parcouru des centaines de
rencontres et surtout un rêve plus
persistants et si nous pouvions vivre
sans argent car sert ce voyage n'a pas
été complètement sans argent nous avons
même utiliser 70 euros pour refaire mon
passeport et payer quelques taxes aux
frontières
mais nous avons surtout découvert une
autre réalité un monde fait de partage
d'entr'aide où les où les humains sutton
s'échangent les ressources qui sont
disponibles c'est ce qui nous amène à
retourner en europe
donc pour moi le retour en france est
avant tout synonyme de retour à la
réalité
il prend la forme d'une douleur
lancinante au niveau des molaires g22
carrie sûrement grâce aux hautes et
qu'elle est marocain offre à tous à tout
va
là vous allez me dire se balader sans
argent c'est une chose pour se soigner
comment fait on j'avoue moi même avoir
du mal à y croire quand ma soeur me
présente sa dentiste qui avait suivi mon
aventure et qui me dit ok on peut faire
un deal non monétaires ont déjà le me
soigne mes dents parce qu'il y avait
urgence
il trouve une compensation avec sa mère
je me retrouve donc à tenir compagnie à
une vieille dame de 84 ans a occupé son
jardin faire quelques petites
réparations et surtout à l'écouté ça
dure un mois et demi c'est une
expérience très riche est pour moi une
confirmation
j'imagine ce monde où il y aurait des
personnes avec des besoins et d'autres
personnes avec des ressources et que
tout s'équilibre
j'avais besoin d'un soin une dentiste
m'a aidé une dame avait besoin de
présence j'ai pu lui donner cette
présence là je me dis que c'est possible
un seul problème un vrai hic ce n'est
pas légal c'est du travail au noir
ça ne rentre pas dans le cadre juridique
légal vendre des armes saleh en france
par contre donné un coup de main ne faut
pas le faire donc nous avons un vrai
problème
pourtant j'en suis convaincu l'économie
du temps et quelque chose faisable
équipe est une réelle alternative
économique pour ce système
certains économistes défendent bernard
maris ce jean michel cornu même charlie
sheen stan aux états unis il stipule que
cette économie est l'une des seules qui
peut permettre une distribution
équitable des richesses entre tous selon
les besoins de chacun le gros avantage
aussi c'est que le don rend heureux
autant celui qui donne que celui qui
reçoit le problème la comptabilisation
peut-on comptabilisé l'économie du don
non c'est impossible c'est à dire
contraire à son principe de base
l'inconditionnalité que faire comment
pouvons nous donc le légaliser
une seule solide et une piste le mettre
en pratique
c'est là que prend le son sens notre
projets d'écovillages donc nous voulons
ouvrir un espace une sorte de
laboratoire vivant pour expérimenter
l'économie du don donner de notre temps
de notre énergie de nos surplus et sans
ne rien attendre en retour se calquer en
gros sur le modèle naturel sur l'arbre
qui donne ses fruits
concrètement nous produirons des paniers
de fruits et légumes bio que nous
donnerons personnes qui ne peuvent pas
se l'offrir
nous donnerons des cours de français
d'espagnol de musique d'orthophonie
d'architecturé naturel organiseront des
conférences d'été toc
des ateliers pour faire des panneaux
solaires ou toutes sortes de machines
sans électricité nous participerons dans
la vie des communes alentour les
aideront dans cette idée de s'orienter
vers une politique de zéro déchet parce
qu'on du temps avec les personnes âgées
organiseront toutes sortes d'activités
et surtout nous ouvrirons l'espace pour
que d'autres personnes puissent venir
expérimenter avec nous pour apprendre à
recevoir parce qu'au final c'est ce
qu'il ya de plus dur
donner c'est facile me recevoir c'est
plus difficile parce qu'il ya ce
sentiment d'infériorité pour apprendre à
recevoir pour ensuite pouvoir donner en
toute humilité
ce ne sera pas parfait nous allons
donner ce que nous pouvons donner en
fonction de nos ressources et quand nous
aurons besoin de quelque chose nous le
demanderons ça fonctionnera pas ce que
ça fonctionne comme le carmin nous y
croyons ça peut paraître utopique comme
ça mais c'est pour ça que le projet
s'appelle et autopia tas pour nous
l'utopie c'est un peu comme l'horizon
c'est un objectif vers lequel il faut
tendre
donc ce ne sera pas parfait il y aura
des taxes et des impôts à payer d'autres
charges sûrement pour ça nous ferons
appel à des dons financiers que nous
utiliserons en toute transparence nous
utiliserons donc de l'argent forcément
au début peut-être qu'après nous
pourrons trouver le moyen de faire sans
nous en sommes convaincus d'ailleurs
qu'il faudra trouver le moyen il faudra
que nous trouvions le moyen
d'expérimenter de montrer ce prototype
de s'orienter vers une société nouvelle
pour que l'état en tous cas la société
se force à définir un cadre légal parce
que l'économie du don au fond c'est
quelque chose qui existe il ya sept
milliards d'êtres humains qu'ils
utilisent au quotidien vous même ici je
suis sûre que vous donnez pouvait lever
la main ce qui donne au quotidien ça peu
du temps de l'énergie voilà tout le
monde
on est tous dans le don c'est juste que
le don c'est pas une économie légale
c'est pas une économie reconnu alors que
pouvons nous faire
que pouvons nous faire pour que cette
économie reprenne sa place parce
qu'avant c'était le seul système
économique naturel qui existait donc
nous pouvons expérimentés nous pouvons
créer des espaces de gratuité des
écovillages comme et autopia tout
simplement donné
donnez aujourd'hui continuer à alimenter
cette économie pour que petit à petit
elle en fait est qu'elles prennent de la
place par rapport à l'économie
financière
si comme moi vous êtes persuadés que
l'économie actuelle l'économie basée sur
la monnaie sur les finances crée des
inégalités que vous aimeriez le changer
en vous disant que c'est peut-être pas
possible que nous sommes impuissants
ben je n'ai pas spécialement de grandes
théories désolé j'aimerais mais juste
une simple invitation de données que
nous pouvons donner un petit peu plus
chaque jour de fortifier cette économie
du thon cette économie parallèle pour
qu'elles puissent peu à peu étouffé
cette autre économie et je suis sûr
qu'ensemble nous pourrions arriver un
jour à répondre à tous nos besoins dans
le don si nous nous y mettons tous
ensemble voilà donnons de nom parce que
la nature donne dos non parce que ça
nous rend heureux aujourd'hui pour
demain merci